welcome to the man of recaps this is the
ridiculously abridged 5 minute Game of
Thrones recap the good guys are the
Starks they live in the north and
they're the ones who say winter is
coming Ned Stark is good friends with
the fat King Rob Ratheon but the Queen
Cersei Lannister is the worst she's got
a twin brother Jaime and they are into
twincest oh so the Prince Joffrey is an
incest baby and maybe that's why he's
such a [ __ ] Ned Stark figures it out but
too late the King already died so
Joffrey takes the throne and you thought
Ned Stark was the main character but his
heads cut off his son Robb Stark is
named king in the north and he goes to
war to avenge his father but he marries
for love breaking a betrothal so he's
betrayed and killed at the red wedding
you thought he was the main character
but he's dead - the fat King's brothers
both claimed the throne but Stannis is
working with a red priestess who uses
shadow magic to assassinate his brother
Renly with the united army he sails for
King's Landing but the Lannisters have a
surprise for him
wildfire boom blows up his whole fleet
so it looks like the Lannisters one
until Joffrey is poisoned at his own
wedding and it looks like the killer is
his uncle tyrion tyrion is the good
lannister he's the dwarf who enjoys
drinking and making funny quips his
trial is a joke because his sister
Cersei hates him and his dad Tywin
really hates him so he demands trial by
combat and it's the Viper versus the
mountain epic Oh Tyrians guy won until
he starts showboating and gets his head
crushed so Tyrion sentenced to death but
his brother Jaime breaks him out but
Tyrion swings by his dad's room finds
him on the pooper and buildin crossbows
him now across the sea is Daenerys
Targaryen the last living member of the
old Targaryen dynasty she marries horse
Barbarian called Drogo making her the
Khaleesi
she gets some dragon eggs as a wedding
gift but dragons are extinct they
definitely won't hatch long story short
though Khal Drogo dies and the dragons
do hatch whoa she trades a dragon for a
slave army but then just kidding I'm
keeping both but who whom conquer
slavers Bay and freeze all the slaves
she loiters for a few seasons but then
Tyrion meets up with her and she's
sailing for Westeros to claim her
birthright the Iron Throne now Ned Stark
had a bastard son named Jon Snow
he joins the Nights Watch who guard the
wall from the terrors beyond the White
Walkers don't worry they're just a myth
but turns out they're not so mythical
and they raise an army of I
Zombies but the Nights Watch doesn't
like that John made friends with the
wildlings
so they mutiny and Julius Caesar him oh
you thought he was the main character
but now he's dead too except the red
priestess was there and cast revive on
him ah who John Snow back to life
he gets his friends together to
reconquer Winterfell from Ramsay Bolton
who's a very bad guy he's also a bastard
so they have an epic battle of the
bastards John wins and now they named
him the king in the north
now Ned Stark had a bunch of kids will
start with Sansa the pretty one who was
engaged to Joffrey but he was awful to
her and they married her to Tyrion who
was nice to her but then they married
her to Ramsay who was the worst but now
she's safe in Winterfell a strong
independent woman Arya Stark is a cute
little fighter she wanders the
countryside and eventually is invited to
join the faceless men Assassin's Guild
she trains to become a Master Assassin
but decides she doesn't like killing
random people so she quits and goes home
to kill people for vengeance bran stark
caught the Lannisters twincest in
episode 1 so Jaime pushed him out the
window and now he's crippled but the
fall awakened his psychic tree powers so
he travels beyond the wall to super tree
and trains with the three-eyed Raven to
learn how to see the past down in King's
Landing Cersei has trouble with a
militant new religious group who makes
her do a naked walk of shame through the
streets she gets revenge by blowing up
the entire church all of her enemies in
one fell swoop and she names herself
queen on the Iron Throne Daenerys is
here now to take it from her and her
dragons are fully grown but the real war
is up in the north John snows going to
fight him and Daenerys brings her
dragons to help but the night king boom
spear o kills a dragon
Cersei agrees to a truce while they all
fight in the zombie apocalypse but of
course she was lying her brother Jaime
he's been on a series long Redemption
arc ever since he got his hand cut off
so he bails on his sister girlfriend and
rides north on his own John Snow and
Daenerys are both really hot so they get
it hon but turns out John Snow is not
Ned Stark's son it was his sister Lyanna
Starks son and his father was Rhaegar
Targaryen oh that makes John Snow the
true king of the Iron Throne hilariously
this makes him Daenerys his nephew but
they don't know that yet and Ponta
nephew incest is relatively tame for
Game of Thrones were ok with
and now the army of the Dead is marching
south luckily there's a huge wall in the
way there's no way they could get past
that unless they had a dead dragon lying
around that they could resurrect as a
zombie dragon booth blue flame and the
wall comes crashing down the army of the
Dead is marching on Westeros and winter
has come so there you have it now you're
basically caught up for the final season
except there's about a hundred important
characters I didn't even get to mention
and a lot of fun interesting plot points
I'd totally skimmed over so if your
interest is piqued go watch my big recap
I go into full detail so it feels like a
real rewatch plus I'm in costume how fun
is that
[Music]